hey baby finally you decide to answer
your phone
ariella confronts bingham about his
suspicious behavior since she's been in
new jersey
you turned off your phone for like three
hours
no i don't turn off the phone i put him
uh
because i'm in the basement obviously
he's hiding something
and their issues only seem to be getting
worse let me tell you something vineyard
shut up
god knows who you
and god knows what you've been doing
oh hey 90 day fans fam it's melicia
not too many updates from the rest of
the cast this week but i wanted to make
sure you saw this musty moment between
ari and binium
number unavailable because his phone is
off if you ask me bam is pressing his
luck i've been in new jersey for a few
weeks now but i'm gonna have to stay
another month so i can get ivy's hernia
surgery done all right at the top of the
episode ari revealed that she now has to
stay in the u.s longer than she expected
because avi's procedure is based on the
doctor's schedule
now let's bring binium into the picture
then i texted him you promised me you
wouldn't turn off your phone anymore
more broken promises according to ari
he's doing this thing where he turns off
his phone for hours at a time and then
gives her no real explanation on why
uh-uh
[Music]
that's the question b
vinnie and i have been arguing because i
haven't been happy that he's been going
out so often and that he didn't tell me
he went out to a nightclub the other
night when she said so often she means
that benny has gone to the club three
weekends in a row
so when he finally answered the video
call i was sitting back just like this
ready to hear what he had to say he'd go
to the club like every weekend for like
three weeks
because now i'm alone like all my
friends just like
they want to invite me because they want
to make me like feel better well this is
what i want to know how many times do
you need to go to the club to feel
better if the club has not helped by now
it does not have your answer bennion
obviously what it's really doing is
making your situation worse for your
friends are not the most important thing
we are supposed to be the most important
thing you would think that during this
time binium would be prioritizing ari's
desire to feel secure within that
relationship so she can for sure come
back with his son but instead he told
her that she's been annoying him yeah
because
before only annoying for me just like
problem like the client and even if she
has been so what
i'm joking well
a little but seriously though there are
better ways to go about addressing ari
blowing up his phone then ignoring her
it's very painful for me when you do not
answer the phone and it makes me
feel like you don't care about me at all
i care about you i care about you now
because i'm working like
workouts i have like workouts
and these friends
ari went on to explain why she gets
concerned when bingham goes out with
them and it all boils down to the good
old saying that never gets old because
it's true
birds of a feather will flock together i
thought that's right i don't have
anything
personally against his friends
my issue is that a lot of them uh don't
have successful relationships or are not
in a relationship or they they don't
have the same value system that i want
to impart to my child and to vinnie and
i feel like that's why they don't
take him in a good direction oh
i know the feeling of questioning your
partner's friends you sit there and you
think i don't see what they have in
common
but
then you realize the hard truth
you just don't know your partner as well
as you think you do damn
i'm sorry
speaking of bingham's friends we
actually got a chance to see him
interact with them this episode and they
happen to feel some type of way about
ari too
i was areella and ivy
i mean irish you freak out she's not
happy what happened
last time we're going for dinner like
yeah we're going to the club like
makes it seem like they are up to no
good
benjamin went on to tell his friends
that ari is just jealous she never
trusts you or
but
this is not about trusting i feel like
she's jealous which is interesting
because he said the same thing about his
ex-girlfriend after she accused him of
cheating on her with his first american
wife
over canadian
here is when his friend starts to give
their opinion about ari
hey
described ari as having a bit of a
difficult personality which
is fair and then he said that there is a
level of explanation that she requires
and benny can't explain that much so in
turn it makes ahri angry
but um
binyam also doubled down on his claims
that ari is jealous
and said it's gotten worse since she's
been in the u.s
which brings us back to the video call
yep we're not done with that what about
me i need you ivy needs you if you're
going to choose keyword here choose to
stay with someone who has quote unquote
jealousy issues
why make it worse by turning off your
phone
that just intensifies the feeling could
you
not turn off your phone or put it on
airplane mode until i get back to
ethiopia
did you really have to think about it
binyam okay
promise
i promise
i've been so hurt by vinnie's behavior
since i've been in america i mean why is
he turning off his phone if not because
he doesn't want me to know where he is
and what he's doing
obviously he's hiding something
please come back i need you i love you
please
okay i love you too
bye baby okay i'll talk to you soon oh
rate that thing a one one star please
not for the quality of the video but for
the conversation
i get that binyam is sad and dealing
with some heavy emotions from his past
but it also seems like he's
self-sabotaging right now he's trying to
avoid a situation where already leaves
him but based off this episode it seems
like he's creating circumstances that
make her want to do just that
you know
next week it gets worse i've decided i'm
i'm not coming back to ethiopia
why you did it to me
let me tell you something vineyard
shut up
god knows who you
and god knows what you've been doing
this is a chance for you to redeem
yourself this is your last
chance
wow
i'm wondering if ari said this i decided
i'm i'm not coming back to ethiopia just
to see how he would react if so i'm not
gonna lie that's kind of harsh
well next week we'll see what goes down
all right 90 day fans fam make sure you
stick with et because we are covering it
all i will see you next time
[Music]
you